une conversation anonyme entre un
policier et une victime de violences
sexuelles sexistes ou conjugal depuis un
an 18 policiers se relaient 7 jours sur
7 au 3e étage du commissariat de
guyancourt
inauguré par plusieurs ministres cette
plateforme permet aux victimes de
pouvoir s'exprimer ou se confier
plus de 5000 signalements ont été
enregistrés dont 35% été transmis aux
services territoriaux pour des dépôts de
plainte ou encore des prises de procès
verbaux nous avons des chat qui viennent
d'outre-mer mais également d'un peu
partout en france surtout sur des
grosses villes on ne peut quand même
dire que paris bordeaux lyon lille ont
beaucoup plus de deux contacts chat que
deux villes un peu plus petite au centre
de la france en moyenne un chat avec une
une victime c'est environ 54 minutes
c'est une moyenne
on a des tchats beaucoup plus longue qui
peuvent durer jusqu'à deux heures
les signalements concernent en premier
les violences sexuelles
viennent ensuite les violences
conjugales et des violences sexistes
tous ces policiers ont reçu une
formation spécifique et sont épaulés par
camille puni c'est la psychologue de
cette plateforme est les accompagnent au
quotidien
il y en a qui apprécient pouvoir durant
un temps ensuite parlé avec moi de
certains chap qu'ils ont vu qu'ils ont
pu plus les marques et que d'autres
j'essaie de rester au maximum disponible
pour pouvoir répondre à toutes leurs
questions
sachant que le but c'est qu'il soit
quand même autonome qui puisse répondre
eux mêmes aux victimes
moche un peu le filet de secours lorsque
effectivement sont en difficulté la
plateforme ouverte à toutes et tous
pourrait être amené à évoluer avec le
recrutement de nouveaux opérateurs ou
l'élargissement du domaine des
infractions